bonjour à tous je vous propose ce matin
de revoir les meilleurs moments de
l'examen au Sénat du projet de loi de
révision constitutionnelle alors comme
vous le savez les sénateurs ont adopté
une version profondément modifiée du
texte issu de l'Assemblée nationale à
l'article 1 sur l'état d'urgence ils ont
notamment renforcé les garanties
apportées avec un contrôle accru du
Parlement et puis à l'article 2
l'article sur la déchéance de
nationalité ils ont adopté l'amendement
de Philippe Bas le président de la
commission des lois amendement qui
limite la déchéance de nationalité au
seul Français titulaire d'une autre
nationalité c'était vous le savez la
ligne rouge fixée par une grande
majorité de sénateurs de la patridie
alors le vote solennel sur l'ensemble du
texte aura lieu cet après-midi et vous
pourrez le suivre bien sûr en direct sur
notre
antentine
vous avez la parole monsieur le Premier
ministre je vous remercie monsieur le
président monsieur le garde des saau
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs il y a 4 mois notre pays était
frappé par le terrorisme islamiste
frappé dans sa chair frappé une nouvelle
fois moins d'un an après la tuerie de
Charlie Hebdo l'assassinat d'une
policière municipale à montrrouge et
l'attaque de l'hypercachè notre pays a
été frappé sur son sol il est frappé à
l'étranger et mes pensées vont vers tous
ceux lâchement abattus à
wagadougu il y a quelques semaines et
dimanche en Côte d'Ivoire ce pays amis
qui comme la Tunisie le Mali le Burkina
Faso est visé parce qu'il est un symbole
de la démocratie et de la réconciliation
en Afrique la France est pleinement
totalement au côté de nos amis Ivoiriens
l'autre pays a été frappé et c'est aussi
toute l'Europe qui vit sous la menace
l'intervention hier des forces de
l'ordre belge et la traque en cours à
Bruxelles
lié directement aux attentats de Paris
nous le
rappelle la cible des terroristes est
chaque fois la même ce sont les valeurs
démocratiques la
liberté l'idéal de tolérance de respect
notre cohésion nationale et aussi le
principe de laïcité la cible c'est ce
que nous sommes et je pense notamment à
la
jeunesse il y a 4 mois
jour pour
jour le chef de l'État au lendemain de
l'horreur s'adressait à Versailles à
tous les représentants de la nation
réunis en
congrès ce jour-là jour d'unité chacun
s'est levé chacun applaudit pour dire
son engagement commun à assurer la
sécurité de nos compatriotes et à mener
cette guerre qui nous a été déclarée
c'est cette même unité qui a présidé à
l'adoption dès le 20 novembre de la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence un texte
adopté dans cette chambre à l'unanimité
et le 9 février à une large majorité
vous avez voté une nouvelle prolongation
jusqu'au 26 mai cette même unité les
députés de la majorité et de
l'opposition l'ont démontré lorsqu'ils
ont adopté ensemble à plus de 35e des
voix le projet de loi constitutionnel
qui vous est soumis à présent oui dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée droite et
gauche malgré les débats tout le monde
les connaît en leur sein ont su dépasser
l'éclivage et se rassembler c'est ce
même chemin que nous devons prendre ici
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
l'exigence d'aujourd'hui est exactement
la même qu'il y a 4 mois rien ne serait
pire que d'avoir la mémoire courte de
céder à cette fâcheuse tendance de notre
époque celle qui veut qu'un événement
chasse l'autre n'oublions pas l'état
d'esprit de novembre ne laissons jamais
retomber nos compatriotes ne le
comprendrai pas cette exigence
d'efficacité bien sûr contre la menace
contre le terrorisme mais aussi cette
exigence d'unité une unité sans faille
car la menace est plus forte que jamais
depuis leurs bastion de Syrie d'Irak
ou du Yémen depuis certaines zones de
repli au Maghreb ou au cell DAEs l'État
islamique ou alqïda ou HMI leur
succursal sont à l'offensive
bririgadant de jeunes combattants
asservissant des populations détournant
des richesses spoliant ces populations
pratiquant la contrebande pour se
financer leur volonté c'est d'étendre
leur emprise territoriale et de
déstabiliser les états c'était le but de
l'attaque menée la semaine dernière
depuis la Libye contre la ville
tunisienne de bengardan ou encore je
l'ai évoqué de la fusillade de Bassam en
Côte d'Ivoire
l'ennemi ce sont ceux qui pent violent
tuent réduisent en esclavage ceux qui
là-bas commettent des attentats et en
planifie d'autres sur notre sol
l'ennemi ce sont aussi ces individus
embrigadés ces cellules plus ou moins
autonomes plus ou moins organisé qui
peuvent agir ici en France au cœur de
notre société ce sont ces ressortissants
français ce sont ces résidents en France
radicalisés imbibé de propagande pr à
prendre les armes pour frapper d'autres
Français pr à tourner les armes contre
leur propre pays à ce jour et le
ministre de l'Intérieur évoque
régulièrement ces chiffres plus de 2000
français ou résidents en France ont été
recensés pour leur implication dans les
filières jihadistes
sirro-irakiennes depuis le début de
l'insurrection en Syrie plus d'un
milliers d'entre eux ont rejoint cette
zone de combat plus de 600 s'y trouvent
toujours dont environ un/ers de femmes
beaucoup de mineurs aussi et
167 167 il ont trouvé la mort la justice
et les services de police agissent sans
relâche depuis le début de l'année
Bernard casazenuve rappelit ce chiffre
en conseil des ministres ce matin 74
personnes ont été interpellés au titre
de leur implication dans la mouvance
jihadiste 28 d'entre elles ont été
placés en détention
provisoire face au terrorisme islamiste
nous agissons nous devons agir à la
racine en frappant militairement au sel
ou au Levant nous jagissons en
renforçant les moyens les effectifs de
nos forces de l'ordre de nos services de
renseignement et de justice en
mobilisant nos soldats dans le cadre de
l'opération sentinelle en luttant bien
sûr contre la radicalisation et en
adoptant notre droit nous l'avons fait
ensemble au Parlement en votant des
dispositions renforçant l'efficacité de
la lutte antiterroriste et donnant enfin
un véritable statut légal aux techniques
de renseignement assortie du contrôle
nécessaire nous continuons à le faire
avec notamment le projet de loi porté
par le Garde des saau qui ce texte a lui
aussi été adopté par une large majorité
à l'Assemblée et que vous examine
très prochainement et je ne doute pas là
encore que le Sénat prendra toute sa
part comme il l'a déjà fait je pense au
proposition que vous avez formulé dans
la proposition de loi portée par
Philippe Bas et Michel Mercier adapter
notre droit c'est aussi adapté notre
Constitution le projet de loi qui vous
est soumis prévoit dans son article 1er
l'insertion dans la constitution d'un
nouvel article l'article 361 concernant
l'état du d'urgence il s'agit de donner
à ce régime de crise un fondement
incontestable je rappelle que le Conseil
d'État lui-même soulignait en décembre
dernier l'intérêt juridique de cette
modification constitutionnelle l'état
d'urgence et le régime de crise le plus
fréquemment utilisé sous la 5e
République vous l'aviez justement
constaté dans un rapport produit par
votre assemblée au mois de février il
serait incohérent de ne pas l'inscrire
dans notre loi fondamentale au même
titre que les régimes prévus aux
articles 16 et 36 de la Constitution ce
n'est pas qu'une question de cohérence
formelle la Constitution c'est règle que
nous nous fixons souverainement ce texte
qui garantit les droits des individus et
qui fonde la démocratie pouvait-elle
rester muette sur l'état d'urgence non
cette inscription qui avait d'ailleurs
été souhaitée notamment il y a quelques
années par le comité présidé par Édouard
Baladur apportera davantage de garanties
les dispositions relatives à l'état
d'urgence ne pourront plus être modifié
par la loi ordinaire désormais ces
motifs et ses conditions de déclaration
sa durée initiale et les modalités de sa
prorogation seront fixés dans la
constitution de même que les conditions
dans lesquelles le Parlement contrôlera
sa mise en œuvre et je le dis ici comme
je l'ai dit devant l'Assemblée nationale
l'état d'urgence n'est pas contraire à
l'état de droit à nos libertés
fondamental c'est une modalité
d'application de l'État de droit
inscrire dans la Constitution ce régime
dérogatoire et provisoire aujourd'hui
prévu par la loi c'est conforter notre
démocratie la semaine dernière votre
commission des Lois a examiné le texte
tel qu'il a été adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale elle s'est prononcé en faveur
de plusieurs amendements qui seront
présentés en séance publique bien sûr
par votre rapporteur le président
Philippe B et nous en débatttrons ces
amendements visent à modifier le projet
existant sur plusieurs points en
rappelant tout d'abord les prérogative
de l'autorité judiciaire gardienne de la
liberté de la liberté individuelle même
si je tiens à souligner le contrôle
strict exercé par la justice
administrative sur les mesures mises en
œuvre depuis le 14 novembre dernier en
prévoyant ensuite la possibilité pour le
Parlement de débattre à tout moment en
séance publique de l'état d'urgence le
cas échéant en examinant une proposition
de loi visant à y mettre fin en limitant
à 3 mois la durée maximale de
progogation contre 4 dans dans la
version adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale enfin en prévoyant que les
mesures prises en application de l'état
d'urgence seront définie par une loi
organique et non par une loi ordinaire
je rappelle d'ailleurs que ces mesures
en particulier les perquisitions
administrativ et les assignations à
résidence seront précisé et mieux
encadré par un projet loi dont un avant
projet a déjà été rendu public qui vous
sera soumis à l'issue de cette procédure
de révision constitutionnelle nous n
poursuivrons ainsi la modernisation de
la loi de 1955 initiée avec le projet de
loi adopté le 20 novembre dernier une
modernisation nécessaire en particulier
au regard de la mise en œuvre actuelle
de l'état d'urgence il faut l'adapter à
la menace et au monde actuel ces
nouvelles dispositions créeront des
mesures de contrainte individualisées et
amélioreront le régime juridiquequ des
perquisitions administratives elles
prendront bien évidemment en compte les
exigences que le conseil titutionnelle a
fixé dans sa décision du 19 février
dernier à propos des copies de données
informatiques réalisées lors des
perquisitions administrative cette
décision par ailleurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs lève
définitivement je crois l'interrogation
sur la nécessité de la
constitutionnalisation de l'état
d'urgence nous examinerons avec
Jean-Jacques urvoise tous ces
amendements avec un esprit constructif
dès lors qu'ils seront conformes aux
principes qui ont guidé notre travail
sur cette révision constitutionnel
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs mardi
dernier avec le garde des saau j'ai
également exposé devant votre commission
des Lois la position du gouvernement
concernant le second article de ce
projet de loi nous abordons ces débats
dans le même esprit que lors des
discussions à l'Assemblée nationale
celui du rassemblement autour des
valeurs qui fondent notre vie en société
celui aussi bien sûr de l'unité
nationale
c'est engage de cette unité
nationale je veux le rappeler aussi que
le Président de la République a proposé
la déchéance de nationalité qui était
demandé faut-il le rappeler dans les
rangs de
l'opposition le texte qui vous est
soumis est le fruit de débat très riche
passionné c'est normal dès lors qu'on
aborde ces questions des débats qui en
fin de compte ont répondu à cette
question qu'est-ce pour nous dans notre
héritage dans notre tradition une nation
et la réponse ce n'est pas seulement le
droit du sang ou du sol c'est d'abord
une exigence permanente qui vaut pour
chacun d'entre nous être français
appartenir à la communauté nationale ce
n'est pas seulement partager une langue
même si c'est beaucoup ou un territoire
c'est avoir une histoire et un destin
commun c'est partager un même amour de
la patrie c'est un serment sans cesse
renouvelé au Pact République aux valeurs
qui le fonde liberté égalité fraternité
qui doivent bien sûr s'incarner dans les
faits et dans les politiques publiques
notre conception de la nation ne peut
pas être à géométrie variable elle
s'applique de la même manière que l'on
soit mononational ou plurinational né
français ou naturalisé et c'est cela le
sens de l'article 2 un sens que j'assume
bien sûr que le gouvernement assume en
étant ant pleinement conscient de la
gravité peut y avoir aucune légèreté
dans ce
domaine-là attaché à toute privation de
nationalité car écartter de la
communauté nationale un individu sans
autre nationalité c'est prendre le
risque de la patridie je veux
aborder ce sujet très directement sans
détour et avec franchise le gouvernement
a d'abord voulu exclure ce risque en
limitant la déchéance de nationalité aux
seuls binationaux c'était d'ailleurs le
sens de l'intervention du président de
la République le 16 novembre comme le
propose à nouveau par amendement
certains d'entre vous mais vous le savez
il y a eu un débat des voix se sont
faites entendre sur divers bandes de
l'Assemblée nationale et bien au-delà
dans le débat public certains ont dit
que ce débat a duré depuis trop
longtemps mais d'abord c'est l'agenda de
toute réforme
constitutionnelle et puis ce sont des
débats graves comment la France ne
pourrait pas aborder ces questions
franchement lucidement alors que les
Français au mois de janvier 2015 se sont
plus que jamais emparés de ces valeurs
de la République et qu'au lendemain des
attentat du 13 novembre ils se sont de
nouveau emparés pleinement de ce qu'est
la nation des voix se sont élevées pour
contester la distinction faite entre les
Français comm étant des actes
terroristes selon qu'ils ai ou non
une seconde
nationalité face à la violence de
l'attaque face à la barbarie des
attentats qui ont frapper notre pays
tous considèrent à raison que le risque
d'apatridi ne peut en aucune manière
affranchir de cette sanction ceux qui
avec les armes ont déchiré ont rompu le
pacte républicain et c'est d'ailleurs ce
que le Sénat avait considéré comme sage
en
1998 à un moment où la menace terroriste
n'était pourtant pas ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi après ces
débats le gouvernement a proposer non
plus
d'exclure mais de limiter ce risque
d'apatridie le limiter d'abord par les
conditions posé par l'article 2 pour
prononcer la déchéance de nationalité
condamnation pénale préalable ce que
n'exige pas la convention de 1961 sur la
réduction des cas d'apatrid convention
nous souhaitons ratifier
limitation aux crimes et délits
constitutifs d'atteinte à la vie de la
nation crimes et délit c'était dans le
texte initial proposé par le
gouvernement ça n'était pas la version
du Conseil d'État l'Assemblée nationale
a modifié c'était une proposition
notamment de l'opposition ajoute de la
possibilité pour le juge de prononcer la
déchéance des droits attachés à la
nationalité afin de proportionner la
réponse de l'État à la dangerosité des
individus concernés limité le risque
d'apatridiie ensuite dans l'avantprjet
de loi rendu public je l'ai indiqué à
votre commission des Lois la semaine
dernière ce texte d'application opère
deux choix très importants il définit
d'abord ce qui constitue une atteinte à
la vie de la nation ce sont ce sont les
crimes et délits constitutifs d'actes
terroristes ou attentatoir aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation prévu au livre
4 du Code pénal pour les délits les
délit je veux le rappeler seuls les plus
graves ont été retenus ceux qui en cour
une peine de 10 ans d'emprisonnement
c'est cohérent d'ailleurs et il faut la
cohérence dans ce domainelà avec les six
déchéances prononcées depuis 2014 engagé
par mes propre soin quand j'étais
ministre de l'intérieur ou par Bernard
Caseneuve toutes pour des délis
d'association de malfaiteurs avisé
terroriste déchéan de la nationalité qui
concerernent à ce moment-là des
binationaux et qui n'avait pas soulevé
de contestation ou de remarques
particulières le texte d'application
modifie ensuite le régime de la
déchéance pour en faire une peine
complémentaire nous proposons ainsi que
la compétence pour prononcer une
sanction qui revient aujourd'hui à
l'autorité administrative après toujours
toujours avis conforme du Conseil d'État
reviennent à l'autorité
judiciaire mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
le gouvernement a bien noté les
amendements l'amendement déposé par les
présidents bas
émerciers qui propose au contraire de
figer l'état du droit actuel jusque dans
la Constitution je respecte le
bicaméralisme je respecte profondément
le
Sénat et je connais son indépendance il
est libre faut-il le
rappeler et encore davantage dans une
révision constitutionnelle qui
nécessite un vote conforme des deux
chambres et ensuite une majorité des 35è
au congrès de proposer d'amender
d'enrichir tout texte il y a pas de
texte à prendre ou à laisser mais nous
sommes dans un
débat nous sommes au début de ce débat
ici au Sénat et je veux poser
directement cette question et vous posez
cette question
quelles sont les intentions de la
majorité
sénatoriale quel message est ici envoyé
au
français souhaitez-vous vraiment
remettre en cause une décision qui a sur
rassembler à l'Assemblée nationale les
deux grandes famille politique dans quel
but ces questionsl ces questions-là je
vous les pose et je ne doute pas un seul
instant que vous y répondrez et je le
dis ici très tranquillement très
sereinement mais c'est une lourde
responsabilité il ne sert à rien
monsieur le Président bas monsieur le
ministre Mercier mesdames et messieurs
parce que j'ai entendu la remarque il ne
sert à rien je vous le dis évitons les
sophismes d'abriter cette posture
derrière les propos du président de la
République devant le
Congrès ces propos ces propos tous ici
nous les avons entendus et tous ici
nous savons aussi que le chef de l'État
a confié au Parlement c'est son rôle de
constituant et c'est l'honneur de la et
la responsabilité de la démocratie c'est
son rôle c'est sa tâche d'élaborer un
consensus sinon il ne peut pas y avoir
de révision ce consensus nous l'avons
construit à l'Assemblée nationale
gouvernement majorité mais aussi une
très large part de l'opposition ce n n
pas un compromis entre députés de gauche
à l'intérieur du groupe socialiste de
l'Assemblée nationale comme j'ai pu
l'entendre ce matin sur une radio ce
texte qui vous est soumis aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus celui du gouvernement ce
n'est pas celui du groupe majoritaire de
l'Assemblée nationale ce n'est pas la
victoire d'un camp sur un autre ce texte
est le fruit d'un consensus
responsable méticuleux exigeant et c'est
le résult
vous le savez en tout cas pour ce qui
concerne l'Assemblée nationale d'un pas
que chaqueun a su faire vers l'autre et
vous le savez ce consensus a été
difficile parfois douloureux dans ma
propre famille politique mais aussi dans
les autres groupes et ceux de
l'opposition je me'y suis
personnellement profondément engagé
parce que je pense qu'il est
important de construire ce type de
consensus et plus de 35è des députés
l'ont adopté de la majorité comme de
l'opposition avec bien sûr des
différences des divisions au sein de
chaque famille mais il y a eu les
35è tous ont su se dépasser alors je
regrette profondément à ce stade bien
sûr que cette construction collective ne
puisse pas être confortée au Sénat à
l'Assemblée nationale nous avons cherché
et construit un accord au Sénat en tout
cas à ce stade vous ne l'avez pas
recherché avec personne et je m'en
étonne vous refusez ainsi à ce stade
bien sûr sur la base de ce qui a été
adopté à l'Assemblée un accord avec
cette dernière et vous le savez
parfaitement car il faut se parler aussi
directement votre proposition ne sera
jamais adoptée par une majorité de
députés je
serai je serai donc je serai donc très
direct l'amendement adopté par votre
commission des Lois prend le contrepied
du consensus et je ne vois pas là de
respect de la parole du président de la
République face face à cette
position je vous remercie d'être les
meilleurs porte-paroles du président de
la République mais laissez-moi en
sourire un tout petit peu et je vous
vois monsieur carucci vouloir être le
porte-parole du président de la
République je croyais que ici vous
portiez la parole d'un ancien président
de la République face à cette position
je veux exposer les raisons je l en
souriant qui ont justifié le choix du
gouvernement en accord avec 3/5e des
députés
car car car je veux convaincre de
participer à la construction de ce
la première
raison ça c'est bien parti je le
reconnais je viens de le rappeler la
première raison c'est le souci
d'efficacité cette peine de déchéance
sera prononcée immédiatement au moment
même de la condamnation par des juges
spécialisés dans la lutte antiterroriste
et notamment par la Cour d'Assise
spéciale deè raison le respect de
l'exigence d'individualisation de la
peine je l'ai dit la ch change de
nationalité est une peine lourde de
conséquence qui nécessite un examen au
cas par cas c'est l'essence même de la
justice pénale d'individualiser la
sanction et donc bien sûr la déchéance
comme dans le droit actuel sera
dépourvue d'automaticité enfin 3è raison
la volonté de construire au sein d'un
régime unifié une sanction globale
prononcée en même temps que la peine
principale par les mêmes juges et non
plus tard par une autor administrativ
différent disposant de tous les éléments
de fait et de droit
ainsi lorsque le juge écartera la
déchéance de la nationalité parce qu'il
considéra cette sanction
disproportionnée il disposera encore de
la déchéance des droits attachés à la
nationalité pour compléter la peine
principale d'emprisonnement avec toute
la fermeté nécessaire certes ces
privations de droit existent déjà dans
le code pénal mais pour certaines avec
des durées limité nous proposons ainsi
d'ajouter aux peines complémentaires une
nouvelle peine la déchéance de
nationalité et de leur conférer à toutes
un caractère définitif le Conseil
constitutionnel l'autorise compte tenu
de la gravité des infraction visé sous
réserve bien entendu d'ouvrir une
possibilité de relèvement ce que nous
proposons au terme d'un délai de 10 ans
à compter de la condamnation mesdames
messieurs les
sénateurs solution proposée par le
gouvernement est respectueuse de l'État
de droit puisqu'elle place au centre du
dispositif l'autorité judiciaire qui seu
pourra prononcer la sanction de
déchéance au terme d'un procès équitable
respectueux des droits de la défense et
garant de l'individualisation de la
sanction cette solution est également
respectueuse de la tradition
républicaine qui a fait de la déchéance
une peine prononcée par le juge pénal
notamment en 1927 sous le gouvernement
d'union nationale de
raymondcré cette solution est
respectueuse enfin des droits
fondamentaux de la personne la patride
ce n'est pas comme je l'ai entendu une
mort civile une éternelle errance il
faut ici rappeler que la France en
ratifiant le 8 mars 1960 la Convention
de New York du 28 septembre 1954 a
reconnu un statut protecteur aux
apatriille c'est au nom donc d'une
certaine idée de la nation que le
gouvernement abouti à la rédaction de
l'article 2 je ne peux donc imaginer que
la majorité sénatoriale ne soit pas au
rendez-vous et n nous trompons pas de
combat et prenons garde à ne pas
construire des oppositions inutiles
voire factices en particulier il ne faut
pas construire d'opposition inutile sur
la question du rôle de l'autorité
judiciaire je sais que sur tous les
bancs s'exprime le souci de préserver
l'état de droit et de ne pas céder sur
le terrain de la protection des libertés
et des droits fondamentaux et c'est
d'ailleurs la tradition du Sénat mais
alors comment expliquer le choix d'une
desséance d'une déchéance de nationalité
prononcé seulement contre certains
terroristes par l'autorité
administrative le ministre de
l'Intérieur et seulement pour des crimes
non plus pour les délites terroristes
graves comment expliquer que nous
préférons cela à une déchéance de
nationalité prononcé par un juge pénal
avec possibilité de relèvement je le
disais avec toutes les garanties du
droit en toute transparence y compris
pour les délis d'association de
malfaiteurs àiser terroristes qui
abritent les organisateurs des actes
terroristes aujourd'hui devant vous je
réitère la proposition faite mardi
dernier à votre commission des Lois
inscrire dans la Constitution la
compétence de l'autorité judiciaire pour
prononcer la déchéance de nationalité
réfléchissons bien ensemble fermer cette
porte c'est renoncer au fond peut-être
au seul compromis possible entre
l'exigence d'égalité et le refus de la
patridie l'exigence de sécurité et de
liberté l'exigence d'efficacité et de
respect des droits le gouvernement est
prêt à cette réaffirmation du rôle de
l'autorité judiciaire nous y sommes
prêts parce que c'est ainsi que doit
répondre une nation sûre de ses valeurs
à ce déterminer jusqu'à la mort à
répandre la terreur mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs cette révision
constitutionnelle c'est c'est une des
réponses que notre nation a voulu
apporter aux attaques qui lui ont été
portées et je comprends bien sûr qu'
puisse y avoir des débats et sur un
sujet aussi important qui touche à notre
texte suprême ils sont légitimes et ils
honorent même la démocratie mais dans un
tel moment face à la menace qui pèse sur
notre pays face au ferment de la
division que certains veulent distiller
il ne faut pas perdre l'essentiel de vue
l'unité des Français les Français
attendent de nous que nous schions
rester rassemblés que nous parvenions
ensemble à trouver un chemin commun et
ce dont les Français ne veulent plus ce
sont les postures qui ne font que
diviser après l'Assemblée nationale
c'est à vous mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs d'envoyer ce message qui dit
quelles sont nos valeurs quel est notre
État de droit quelle est notre
conception de la nation le gouvernement
est disponible et toujours disponible
pour trouver le consensus nécessaire
loyalement et franchement sans jouer et
sans nous perdre à vous donc à votre
tour de rappeler ce qui fait notre
force
merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la parole est maintenant
président Philippe B rapporteur de la
commission des
loisésent
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministre monsieur le garde des
saau madame la
Présidente chers
collègues au moment de vous présenter
les quelques réflexions que m'inspire ce
projet de révision
constitutionnel je ne peux
oublier l'ambition qui lui est signé par
le Président de la République qui en a
pris l'initiative devant nous le 16
novembre dernier il s'agit de manifester
dans notre loi
fondamentale le pacte qui unit les
Français dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme après les deux vagues
d'attentats criminels qui ont endeuillé
la France en janvier et en novembre
2015 cette unité est nécessaire
elle marque la
détermination de la représentation
nationale et au-delà la détermination du
peuple français lui-même à vaincre ce
mal
absolu en proclamant l'état
d'urgence le gouvernement que vous
dirigez monsieur le Premier ministre a
pris la bonne
décision et le Sénat de son côté a pris
ses
responsabilité pour renforcer les
pouvoirs du ministre de l'Intérieur et
des préfet et en prorogeant à deux
reprises l'état
d'urgence notre Assemblée a d'ailleurs
constamment était au rende vous de la
lutte contre le
terrorisme nous avons soutenu et
renforcé la loi du 21 décembre 2012
contre le terrorisme de nouveau nous
avons soutenu et renforcé la loi du 13
novembre 2014 avant même les deux vagues
d'attentat que j'ai rappelé de la lutte
contre le terrorisme le 24 juillet
2015 la loi sur le renseignement a été
promulguée j'en ai été le le rapporteur
nous pouvons tous témoigner de la
mobilisation du Sénat pour donner de
nouveaux instruments de lutte contre le
terrorisme et de défense d'ailleurs des
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation et de
nouveau le 20 novembre dernier le 19
février de cette année quand il s'est
agit d'apporter notre soutien à l'état
d'urgence le Sénat n'a pas marchandé son
appui c'est dire
que nous n'avons pas de leçons à
recevoir en ce qui concerne
l'unité de la représentation
nationale pour la
lutte contre le terrorisme le Sénat veut
l'efficacité le Sénat veille aussi à ce
que cette efficacité la plus grande
possible soit acquise dans le respect de
l'État de droit en renforçant les
garanties inscrit dans nos textes pour
chacun des textes que j'ai cité cela a
été le cas c'est la marque de fabrique
de notre assemblée que de vouloir
préserver les libertés et l'état de
droit tout en renforçant les moyens de
la de la lutte contre le
terrorisme devant la gravité de la
situation à laquelle la France est
confrontée depuis les attentats de
janvier puis de novembre 2015 l'état
d'urgence a été déclaré le président de
la République a réuni la représentation
nationale à Versailles et il a annoncé
la révision constitutionnelle dont nous
débattons
aujourd'hui pour permettre je le cite au
pouvoir public d'agir contre le
terrorisme de guerre en conformité avec
les principes de l'État de
droit jugeant l'article 16 et l'état de
si
inadapté à la situation il a considéré
je le cite de nouveau que cette guerre
d'un autre type face à un adversaire
nouveau appelle un régime
constitutionnel permettant de gérer
l'état de crise et il ajoutait qu'il
fallait disposer d'un outil approprié
afin que des mesures exceptionnelle
puissent être prise pour une certaine
durée sans recourir état d'urgence ni
compromettre l'exercice des libertés
publies le 16 novembre dernier le
président de la République a également
fait part à la représentation nationale
réunie à Versailles de sa
décision de proposer au Parlement
l'extension de la peine de déchéance de
nationalité pour acte de terrorisme au
français de naissence
possédant une autre nationalité ce sont
ces termes mêmes
il a décidé
postérieurement à son discours
d'intégrer cette réforme à la révision
constitutionnelle le 23 décembre dernier
c'est donc un texte qui reflétait
fidèlement les intentions du président
de la République qui a été adopté par le
Conseil des ministres avant d'être
libéré par l'Assemblée
nationale la question s'est posée pour
nous tous de savoir si cette inscription
à la fois de l'extension de la déchéance
de nationalité et par ailleurs de l'état
d'urgence dans la Constitution
correspondait à une nécessité juridique
impérieuse je vous avais d'ailleurs
Monsieur le Premier Ministre proposer
comme vous en avez le pouvoir de saisir
le Conseil
constitutionnel de la première loi
prorogeant l'état d'urgence ce que vous
n'avez pas souhaité faire à l'époque
cela nous aurait pourtant permis d'en
avoir le cœur net beaucoup plus tôt
heureusement grâce à la procédure des
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité le Conseil
constitutionnel s'est prononcé à trois
reprises comme il l'avait déjà fait en
1985 d'ailleurs mais de manière à
l'époque plus limitée et il a a
apportter toutes les garanties
nécessaires sur le fait que
naturellement comme on pouvait le penser
le régime de l'état d'urgence est
constitutionnel il n'y a donc pas de
nécessité juridique impérieuse
d'inscrire l'état d'urgence dans la
Constitution pourquoi le ferions-nous
alors nous le ferions parce que
justement monsieur le Premier ministre
nous sommes sensibles à cette exigence
inscrire dans la Constitution qui est le
pacte fondamental qui unit tous les
Français les moyens de la lutte contre
le terrorisme mais si nous le
faisons nous ne voulons le faire qu'à la
condition qu'un certain nombre de
garanties soit apporté par le pouvoir
constituant sur la mise en œuvre de
l'état d'urgence afin qu'il ne puissent
pas en être fait de mauvais usage ce
n'est pas le cas actuellement je men de
le dire mais à partir du moment où nous
mobilisons la Constitution pour
consolider le régime de l'état d'urgence
alors il faut veiller tout
particulièrement aux garanties dont
l'état d'urgence est
assorti puisque cette révision
constitution constitutionnelle n'est pas
absolument nécessaire autant faire en
sorte qu'à tout le moins elle soit
réellement utile et c'est tout le sens
du travail de la commission des
lois s'agissant de la déchéance de la
nationalité la question est plus
délicate nous sommes je le dis tout à
fait d'accord avec ce qu'a dit le
président de la République s'agissant de
la nécessité
d'étendre la possibilité de la déchéance
de nationalité pour des criminels
terroristes au français donner
ayant une autre nationalité car
actuellement seul les Français qui ont
acquis cette nationalité pendant leur
vie sont exposés à la déchéance de
nationalité il s'agit donc d'unifier le
régime de la déchéance de nationalité le
président de la République a souhaité
apporter une limite à cette extension de
la déché
en considérant qu'il ne fallait pas
créer
d'apatride l'Assemblée nationale et
c'est son
droit n'a pas souhaité suivre la
proposition du gouvernement celle du
président de la République sur ce point
et a adopter d'autres
dispositions je dois
dire qu'en matière de déchéance de
nationalité pas plus que pour l'état
d'urgence il ne me semble
pas que l'inscription dans la
Constitution de cette déchéance de
nationalité s'imposait avec la force de
l'évidence mais mais je suis
sensible à l'examen qu'a fait de cette
question le Conseil d'État et je
considère qu'on peut par conséquent euh
estimer qu'il vaut mieux prendre cette
garantie à titre de précaution plutôt
que de se trouver dans la situation où
il n'y aurait pas d'extension de la
déchéance de nationalité du tout et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission des lois a accepter de
rentrer dans le raisonnement que nous
propose le président de la République et
à sa suite le gouvernement en adoptant
une disposition permettant l'extension
de la déchéance de nationalité mais nous
n'avons pas souhaité monsieur le Premier
ministre à la commission des lois
permettre la création d'apatride il y a
une première raison à cela c'est que ce
serait parfaitement inefficace du point
de vue de la lutte contre le terrorisme
parce que on imagine souvent que grâce à
la déchéance de nationalité on va
pouvoir expulser un étranger qui s'est
rendu coupable de CRIM grave oui on doit
pouvoir le faire s'il a une autre
nationalité mais s'il est apatride et
bien s'il est apatride il faut le garder
sur le territoire national car la France
a des engagements internationaux qui
sont très clairs et qui empêche
d'expulser des apatrides elle doit
appliquer une protection qui est celui
qui est celle lié au régime de la
patridie j'ajoute monsieur le Premier
ministre que le débat a été de mon point
de vue rendu plus opaque par les
déclarations du gouvernement car vous ne
pouvez pas à la fois
renoncer à ce qui était au cœur de
l'initiative du Président de la
République à savoir empêcher la patrie
dans la disposition constitutionnelle et
nous dire que cette garantie vous allez
la poser dans un texte subordonné que ce
soit à l'occasion de l'adoption d'une
loi ou à l'occasion de l'adoption d'une
loi autorisant la ratification d'un
traité car s'il s'agit d'une garantie
fondamentale ça n'est pas dans le texte
subordonné qu'elle doit figurer c'est
dans le texte constitutionnel et après
tout c'est vous qui nous invitez à
réviser la Constitution et bien soyons
cohérents
si nous révisons la Constitution ce
n'est pas pour mettre les garanties
essentielles dans des textes de loi
ordinaires ou dans des lois autorisant
la ratification d'une
convention j'ajoute que le texte qui a
été adopté par l'Assemblée nationale sur
cette seule question comporte une
latitude pour le législateur de demain
qui ne lasse pas d'inquiéter les
défenseurs des libertés publiques car au
lieu de circonscrire
strictement la possibilité qu'aurait le
législateur du futur d'autoriser des
déchéances de nationalité il est temps
comme on n'aurait pas pu imaginer de
l'étendre euh si il n'y avait pas cette
révision constitutionnelle la révision
constitutionnelle ça doit nous protéger
pour l'avenir protéger les générations
futures et ça n'est donc pas euh par des
textes qui étendent à l'excès la
possibilité pour le législateur de
porter atteinte à des principes
fondamentaux que nous devons réviser la
Constitution je refuse que cette
révision constitutionnelle soit la porte
ouverte demain à des
excès nous avons à la commission des
lois adopté un certain nombre
d'amendements dans la fidélité à ce qui
fait la vocation même de notre assemblée
en ce qui concerne la défense des
libertés s'agissant de l'état d'urgence
nous avons voulu dire que les mesures
prises dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
comme l'exige déjà le Conseil
constitutionnel doivent être nécessaires
adaptés et proportionnés nous avons
voulu définir avec précision les pouvoir
du Parlement il ne suffit pas de dire
qu'il se réunit de plein droit encore
faut-il préciser ce qu'il a le droit de
faire quand il se réunit de plein droit
et notamment qu'il a le droit de mettre
fin à tout moment à l'état d'urgence et
la commission des lois dans son
unanimité tient beaucoup à cet aspect de
la question et enfin puisque le débat a
lieu puisque nous avons de nombreuses
occasions dans tous les textes que nous
avons débattu sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme de euh rentrer dans ce débat
j'ai souhaité et la Commission des loi
m'a suivi qu'il soit fait référence à
l'article 66 de la Constitution dans la
mise en œuvre des pouvoirs de l'état
d'urgence ça n'est pas parce que nous
faisons un régime de pouvoir
exceptionnel qu'il faut déroger aussi à
l'article 66 de la
Constitution s'agissant de la déchéance
nous respectons le régime actuel de la
déchéance c'est un décret en Conseil
d'État qui vous a fait reproche monsieur
le Premier ministre d'avoir signé des
décrets accordant la déchéance sur avis
conforme du Conseil d'État qui vous a
dit que le Conseil d'État n'avait pas
convenablement rempli son rôle pour
vérifier que les conditions étaient
réunies et pourquoi changer ce système
l'acquisition de la nationalité
française c'est une décision de
souveraineté le retrait ou la déchéance
de la nationalité française c'est aussi
une décision de
souveraineté c'est exact que nous
n'avons pas inscrit les délits parmi les
causes possibles de la déchéance de
nationalité mais je vais vous donner
l'explication Monsieur le Premier
Ministre elle est très simple dans la
proposition de loi que nous avons
débattu nous avons décider que les délit
les plus graves en matière de terrorisme
devaient être désormais qualifié de
crime et être assorti de peine de prison
beaucoup plus lourde mais en revanche
nous ne voulons pas que pour des délits
qui seraient punissables de peine d'un
an de prison le législateur du futur
s'arroge le droit de déchoir de sa
nationalité un délinquant il nous paraît
tout à fait essentiel que la déchéance
de nationalité soit réservée à la
sanction
d'infraction extrêmement grave et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons été
extrêmement intransigents sur ce point
enfin je dois vous dire que il me paraît
indispensable que la condamnation
qui peut donner lieu ensuite à déchéan
de nationalité soit une condamnation
définitive tant qu'on n pas épuisé les
voies de recours il ne doit pas être
question de prononcer la déchéance de
nationalité monsieur le Premier
ministre le Sénat se prononcera en toute
indépendance vous l'avez vous-même
souligné mais nous n'avons pas besoin de
votre autorisation pour
cela
en
fonction de ses propres convictions
comme semble-t-il l'Assemblée nationale
l'a fait elle aussi c'est la condition
d'un dialogue équilibré entre nos deux
assemblée et respectueux de chacune
d'elles et ça n'est pas en renonçant à
nos
conviction que nous ferons aboutir cette
révision constitutionnelle mais au
contraire en posant clairement les
principes qui inspirent notre vote et
nos
amendements je sais
aussi que le compromis qui est intervenu
à l'Assemblée nationale est avant tout
un compromis entre le gouvernement et le
groupe majoritaire à l'Assemblée
nationale car j'ai bien
entendu beaucoup de députés à
l'Assemblée national exprimer leur
attente très forte à l'égard du Sénat
ceuxlà n'ont accepté de se prononcer sur
la révision constitutionnelle que parce
que nous avions pris l'engagement de
réécrire le texte ils ont vis-à-vis de
nous une très forte attente nous ne
souhaitons pas naturellement la
déécevoir et monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez utilisé un
terme excusez-moi je vous demande
de le retirer il n'y a pas eu de
consensus à l'Assemblée nationale j'ai
bien entendu les divisions qui ont
opposé le gouvernement au groupe
majoritair puis les divisions des
membres de ce groupe majoritaire il y a
eu un compromis consensus et compromis
ce n'est pas la même chose et si même si
même il y avait eu et si même il y avait
eu consensus à l'Assemblée nation
je vous rappelle les règles de la
révision constitutionnelle ces règles
sont sages il faut que tous les pouvoirs
publics constitutionnel son en soit
d'accord le président de la République
qui prend l'initiative le gouvernement
qui le lui propose et qui défend le
texte l'Assemblée nationale qui l'adopte
le Sénat qui à son tour ou avant
l'Assemblée nationale selon qu'il est
saisi en premier ou en second adopte le
texte et il y a donc là quatre
institutions qui doivent se mettre
d'accord
sont à égalité de droit ensuite le
président de la République doit proposer
le texte s'il est adopté en terme
d'identique à référendum c'est la règle
de droit commun il peut y échapper s'il
ne souhaite pas faire souscrire le pays
directement à la révision
constitutionnelle en convoquant le
Congrès c'est une formule subsidiaire et
dérogatoire il lui appartient de choisir
naturellement en fonction de la
préférence qu'il manifestera voilà
monsieur le Premier ministre mes chers
collègues ça n'est pas un pas que chaque
camp comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure doit faire vis-à-vis de l'autre
c'est un pas que chaque assemblée doit
faire vis-à-vis de l'autre et que chacun
des quatre pouvoirs publics
constitutionnels doit faire vis-à-vis de
l'autre nous assumerons en ce qui nous
concerne pleinement nos responsabilités
comme nous l'avons toujours fait pour
lutter contre le terrorisme avec plus
d'efficacité et dans le respect de
l'État droit
merci merci monsieur le président de la
commission des lois il est grand temps
de mettre un terme à ce sinistre débat
sur la révision
constitutionnelle qui n'a cessé depuis 4
mois d'abîmer la France et unité des
Français 4 mois perdus à tenté de
justifier un projet de révision
constitutionnel dont l'efficacité face
aux menaces terroristes n'a cessé d'être
contesté par les voies les plus
illustres et les plus diverses et dont
la dangerosité pour nos libertés
fondamentales a été amplement démontré
moi je ne fais pas une loi nous
proposons pas une loi une révision
constitutionnelle et les moyens pour tel
ou tel en fonction de sa religion je le
fais pour protéger tous les Français
parce que ceux qui ont été attaqués ceux
qui ont été tués le 13 novembre à Paris
ils étaient de toutes les confessions de
toutes les religions de toutes les
générations de toutes les couleurs alors
Monsieur Pierre Laurent je suis aussi
républicain que vous aussi attaché à la
République aussi attaché à la démocratie
aussi attaché aux droits fondamentaux de
mon pays aussi attaché que vous et
autant que vous de gauche donc je ne
n'accepterai aucune leçon dans ce
domaineel aucune leçon parce que c'est
trop facile c'est trop facile Monsieur
Pierre Laurent de monter à la tribune du
Sénat de délivrer de leçons sur la
sécurité des Français et de ne voter
aucune loi pour protéger nos
compatriotes madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre messieurs
les ministres Mesdames et Messieurs
chers collègues vous l'avez tous dit
avant moi il y a 4 mois jour pour jour
le 16 novembre nous étions réunis en
congrès à Versailles et le débat que
nous abordons aujourd'hui est
fondamental fondamental dans la lignée
de ce qui s'est passé le 13 novembre et
fondamental dans la lignée de ce qui
s'est passé le 16 novembre au Congrès je
pense qu'il faut comme l'a fait tout à
l'heure le Premier ministre et d'autres
intervenants se replonger à la source de
ce qui nous amène à cette révision
constitutionnelle dans les heures qui
viennent nous devrons dans tout ce débat
nous souvenir de l'esprit de Versailles
oui il existe un esprit de Versailles
celui de la France debout celui de celui
de tous les parlementaires luttant
unanime contre le terrorisme alors
permettez-moi de rappeler quelques faits
le contexte dans lequel s'est tenu ce
congrès
oui vous le saviez nous le savons tous
le 13 novembre 14- 155 le pays était
traumatisé ces attentats ont été
terribles une nuit d'effroid on ne
savait pas combien il y aurait de de
morts l'attente du du bilan était
incertain et surtout nos valeurs avaient
été mises à mal les terroriste avait
attaqué notre cadre de vie nous savions
pas si cela allait reprendre continuer
s'arrêter et combien il y aurait de de
victimes les témoignages que nous avons
eu directement pour les membres du
gouvernement ou nous par les médias nous
a montré combien l'horreur avait frappé
notre sol c'était un weekend de grande
inquiétude ce drame était d'une violence
inimaginable d'ailleurs ce drame nous a
touché nous a tous glacé et durant ces
jours l'exéc a été omniprésent le chef
de l'État s'est rendu sur place et a
montré sa grande capacité à affronter
les événements le Premier ministre les
membres du gouvernement ont géré cette
situation avec
maestria rappelons-nous l'incroyable
gravité de nos
conversations lorsque le président du
Sénat nous appelit pour nous tenir au
courant les présidents de groupe de ce
qui se de ce qui se passait de voir
l'ffroid du peuple les mesures qui ont
été prises la convocation des
parlementaires à l'Élysée le dimanche
l'annulation du congrès annuel des des
maires de France oui le pays a été
touché en son cœur et nous sommes passés
prêts me semble-t-il d'une rupture de
notre pacte républicain nous avions été
quelques-uns à le pointer il y a 4 mois
au congrès de de Versailles il est
important de ne pas laisser germer dans
notre société chez certains de nos
concitoyens le moindre discours de haine
oui de haine contre telle ou telle
catégorie de Français en fonction de sa
religion de ses origines parce qu'il
seraiit différent qu'ils aient des
convictions différentes notre pays était
au bord de la rupture il fallait donc
une réaction à la hauteur de ce
traumatisme et l'exécutif a eu cette
réaction à Versailles moins de 3 jours
après les attaques le chef de l'État a
apporté aux Français des réponse qui à
mon sens ont pu faire oublier cette
rupture le président de la République a
a joué un rôle d'unificateur de la
nation et le congrès au congrès de
versaill nous avons tous applaudi son
discours debout nous l'avons tous fait
parce que c'est une réponse aux actes de
guerre un programme de renforcement de
notre protection une célébration
patriotique utile et nécessaire ce
discours a été salué debout par tous les
parlementaires non pas parce que telle
ou telle phrase y était ou n'y était pas
ce n'était pas l'analyse du texte que
nous applauditions mais c'était bien
parce que le discours entier du chef de
l'État répondait à ce qui se posait
comme un risque pour la nation et je
crois que le Congrès de Versailles à ce
moment-là a été utile à notre pays utile
pour faire face utile pour garder une
unité au moment où le terrorisme nous
ébranlé et oui suite à ce Congrès de
Versailles cette révision
constitutionnelle est utile il est
important de montrer à nos citoyens
l'unité des parlementaires au côté de
l'unité des Français versaill était une
étape nécessaire et cette traduction en
acte était
incontournable tout d'abord nous avons
prolongé l'état d'urgence et puis à
nouveau prolongé ici même et encore
récemment avec une très large majorité
dans dans le même temps l'Assemblée
nationale a fait de même et notamment a
voté récemment le projet de loi pour
renforcer la lutte contre le terrorisme
et son financement nous le voyons nous
sommes capables en tant que
représentation nationale de faire preuve
d'unité quand l'essentiel est en jeu et
cette révision constitutionnelle
s'inscrit dans cette trajectoire elle
est porteuse d'une solidité pour l'état
d'urgence sa constitutionnalisation
c'est inscrire une garantie quant à
l'utilisation de ce régime d'exception
les guerres ont changé de formme les
réponses de notre République doivent
changer aussi et c'est le sens de cet
article 1 j'en viens maintenant pour
conclure à l'article 2 celui qui a fait
débat qui fait le plus débat à droite
comme à gauche le groupe socialiste et
républicaine n d'ailleurs pas unanime
sur ce sur ce texte certains collègues
se posent des cas de conscience c'est
leur libre choix et leur liberté un
amendement soutenu par une trentaine de
nos collègues sera mis en débat pour
supprimer cet article 2 mais dans tous
les groupes politiques à l'Assemblée
comme au Sénat les positions n'ont pas
été unanimes parce que sur des sujets
comme ceci il faut essayer de se
rassembler et je le dis ici je suis
favorable à ce que des terroristes
condamné soit sanctionné par une
déchiance de nationalité nous sommes
nombreux à soutenir la volonté du
Président de la République nous pouvons
acquérir une nationalité mais nous
pouvons aussi la perdre lorsqu'on se
retourne contre la nation cette réforme
constitutionnelle pour qu'elle soit
adoptée il faut qu'elle soit non
partisane 3 de socialistes 35e de
républicains 35e de l'Assemblée
nationale 35e du Sénat et nous pourrions
arriver à cela aujourd'hui mais
l'amendement de du président de la
commission des lois tel qu'il est
présenté aujourd'hui nous semble poser
un problème quant à ce rassemblement et
quant à l'optenation des
35è nous vous savez très bien que
réétablir
explicitement la la mention de
binationaux de plurinationaux dans
l'article 2 revient un texte qui dit
diviserit empêcherit cette réforme
l'Assemblée nationale ne l'accepterait
pas et nous nous ne l'accepterons pas
alors évidemment j'ai entendu ce que
disait le président bas tout à l'heure
le Sénat n'a pas à faire un copiercollé
de l'Assemblée nationale comme disait
monsieur merciier le Sénat n'a pas à
s'aligner devant l'Assemblée nationale
mais évidemment l'inverse non plus
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas à
s'aligner devant le Sénat et n'a pas à
faire un copiercollé de ce qui se
passerait au Sénat et c'est la raison
pour laquelle c'est la raison pour
laquelle pour i si nous sommes tous
honnêtes intellectuellement ce que je
pense et si nous voulons arriver à une
réforme constitutionnelle alors
effectivement il faudra que l'article 2
du Sénat tel qu'il est rédigé par le
président bas s'il doit être voté soit
changer sans cela vous le savez très
bien on va pas se raconter d'histoire
vous le savez très bien si c'est le cas
il n'y aura pas de majorité des 35e il
n'y aura pas il n'y aura pas d'accord
transpartisan donc il n'y aura pas de
congrès et on peut appeler un chat un
chat alors il y a ceux peut-être qui
veulent pour diverses raisons qu'il n'y
ait pas de congrès d'autres qui
souhaitent l'avoir mais en tout cas la
réalité la réalité vous le savez très
bien elle est celle-là alors c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je
voudrais je voudrais lancer un appel
solennel au nom de mon groupe au au
président du Sénat j'ai entendu les
toutes les déclarations du président du
du Sénat je pense monsieur le Président
si vous le jugez utile que vous devri
assez vite convoquer les présidents de
groupe et les groupes de ceux qui
veulent qui sont favorables à ce qu'il y
ait une réforme constitutionnelle à ceux
qui sont favorables que nous avancions
pour préparer une réunion avec
l'Assemblée nationale parce que vous le
savez très bien que ce genre de débat
doit se passer nous sommes des
constituants doit se passer dans
l'hémicycle mais vous savez très bien
que pour y arriver ce n'est pas faisant
un texte ici un texte ailleurs et en
revenant que ça marchera je fais partie
parti de ceux qui pensent que le
Parlement réuni les parlementaires
réunis en constituant ne peuvent pas
sauter à la corde au grré des
amendements ou des textes qui sont mis
ici ou là à l'Assemblée et au Sénat et
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
le Président je pense que si vous
acceptiz cette proposition nous
pourrions peut-être avancer pour trouver
non pas un consensus comme le disait
tout àheure monsieur Mercier en tout cas
un compromis parce que et je conclus en
12 secondes madame la madame la
présidence dans les moments que nous
avons
vécu dans ce pays fracturé divisé avec
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui doute
l'attitude que doivent avoir les
parlementaires réunis pour la réforme
constitutionnelle les parlementaires
constituant CCI d'aller au bout d'aller
au bout de nos convictions d'aller au
bout d'une histoire d'aller au bout tout
simplement de valeurs qui nous sont
chères celles de la République en nous
disant que quand la France est attaquée
quand la la patrie est en danger comme
nos grands anciens nous sommes capables
de nous rassembler au nom des valeurs
cardinales de notre République merci
merci monsieur le Président Guillaume
madame Eser Benbassa pour le groupe
écologiste a maintenant la
parole madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Ministre monsieur le
gardessau monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues le 13 novembre
dernier la France a été frappée par les
attentats les plus meurtriers perpétré
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale 130
personnes y ont perdu la vie l'ampleur
et la violence de ces événements nous
ont rappelé de la manière la plus
douloureuse qui soit la vulnérabilité de
notsre démocratie face à la menace
terroriste réunis en congrès à
Versailles le 16 novembre nous
parlementaires étions convaincus de
l'urgence qu'il y avait d'agir
efficacement contre cette menace pour
assurer la sécurité de nos
concitoyens le président de la
République y a prononcé devant nous et à
l'adresse du pays un discours grave et
fort mais dans l'esprit et le
vocabulaire ont pu surprendre certains
je le cite nous sommes dans une guerre
contre le terrorisme djihadiste qui
menace le monde entier et pas seulement
la
France de quelle guerre parlait donc le
président les criminels qui s'en
prenaient à nous étai donc des
soldats les soldats de quel
état devions-nous donc reconnaître re à
daesh la dignité d'un état dans ce même
discours le président François Hollande
préconiser une réforme de la
Constitution afin de permettre au
pouvoir public d'agir conformément à
l'état de droit contre le terrorisme de
guerre de cette mise en scène est né le
projet de loi constitutionnelle de
protection de la nation qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui une première question vient
à l'esprit est-ce bien le rôle d'une
constitution d'organiser la lutte contre
le terrorisme puis est-il légitime d'y
insérer de nouveaux articles qui à cet
égard même et de l'aveu de tout
observateur
sensé ne seront d'aucune portée
pratique Nils muisniex commissaire au
droit de l'Homme du Conseil de l'Europe
écrit je le cite les terroristes se
nourrissent des peurs ils veulent nous
faire croire que nous devons choisir
entre liberté et sécurité or une
démocratie n'a pas à faire ce choix un
État démocratique doit s'opposer à la
barbarie du terrorisme en évitant
d'affaiblir l'État de droit et le
respect des droits de l'homme ne pas
réussir à trouver cet équilibre serait
une victoire pour les terroristes fin de
citation c'est exactement ce que nous
voulons au lieu de chercher à comprendre
non pour excuser mais pour agir
efficacement et palier nos propres
faiblesses nous continuons d'empiler les
lois liberticide comme nous l'avons fait
après les attaques de janvier 2015 sans
pour autant hélas empêcher la tragédie
du 13
novembre simplement parce que ces lois
ne sont qu'une parade politique qui ne
rassure que l'exécutif et certains
politiciens soucieux de ne pas rater
leur réélection si par malheur un autre
attentat se
produisait mais beaucoup moins nos
concitoyens que l'état de guerre
proclamé plonge dans la paralysie et la
peur d'un même mouvement l'exécutive
tente de divertir ainsi le peuple au
sens pascalien d'autres problèmes aussi
urgents comme le
chômage l'article 1er de notre texte qui
a pour objectif de constitution aliser
l'état d'urgence tiendrait d'une part à
renforcer les garanties des droits
fondamentaux et liberté publique et
d'autrre part à adapter ce régime
d'exception à la nouvelle menace
terroriste ces arguments répétés comme
un mantra lors des débats à l'Assemblée
nationale sont peu convaincants de
quelle garantie
s'agit-il en fait engravant dans le
marbre de la Constitution la possibilité
pour le législateur de fixer les mesures
de police administratives que les
autorités civiles pourront mettre en
œuvre en violation des libertés et
droits fondamentaux c'est au contraire
l'arbitraire du pouvoir législative qui
est ainsi
constitutionnalisée quant à l'idée que
constitutionnaliser l'état d'urgence
permettrait d'adapter ce régime à la
menace terroriste actuelle elle paraît
pour le moins contradictoire l'état
d'urgence est et doit rester une mesure
temporaire prise pour répondre à un
péril imminent or il me semble que le
terrorisme auquel nous faisons face et
pour reprendre l'analyse du politologue
Bernard Manin une menace épisodique mais
par nature
permanente
j'ajouterais que le terrorisme peut être
comparé à l'IDRE de l'Herne de la ologie
antique ce monstre aux multiples têtes
qui repoussait à mesure qu'on les
coupait
s'imaginez pouvoir dissuader d'agir par
laaccumulation de dispositions
législatives des personnes qui n'ont ni
foi ni loi relève de la gajure et trahit
une paresse de l'esprit que nos
gouvernants mettent tant d'énergie à
modifier en 20ain notre Constitution
témoigne aussi du peu de respect qu'ils
ont pour la Constitution elle-même mais
aussi du peu de respect qu'ils ont du
législateur en lui faisant perdre un
temps précieux qu'il pourrait employer à
d'autres objectifs cruciaux comme sortir
le pays du marasme économique si ce
projet avait émané de la droite la
gauche l'aurait critiqué avec
véhémence il me paraît en outre d'autant
plus vite de sens que nous aurons à
débattre bientôt d'un è projet de loi
visant à renforcer la lutte contre le
crime organisé le terrorisme et leur
financement et à améliorer l'efficacité
et les garanties de la procédure pénale
associé à l'article 2 l'article sur
l'état d'urgence contribue à plomber un
peu plus un climat social déjà délétaire
loin de cette unité nationale entre
guillemets qu'il est peut-être sage de
souhaiter facile de proclamé mais
beaucoup plus difficile à
réaliser qui peut croire que l'article 2
qui constitutionnalise la la menace
d'une déchéance de nationalité va nous
protéger des terroristes qui n'ont que
faire de leur nationalité de leur
passeport dois-je rappeler le le clivage
qu'a créé cet article aussi bien à
droite qu'à gauche et pourquoi a-t-il
créé ce clivage parce qu'il ne s'agit
plus ici d'opinion par partisane l'enjeu
est d'une autre nature il s'agit d'une
atteinte aux valeurs cardinales de notre
République il me semble que monsieur le
Premier ministre n'est pas gêné outre
mesure par l'absence de porté pratique
de ces dispositions pourvu que les
symboles y soi c'est un peu ce que
pensaient hier les partisans de la peine
de mort une fois qu'on était parvenu à
leur démontrer son inutilité il y avait
en c le symbole et de quel symbole
parlons-nous ici le d'un symbole négatif
source de division il semble que pour
certains de nos gouvernants l'histoire
singulière de notre pays compte pour
rien l'acrobatie rhtorique à laquelle on
s'est livré en supprimant la mention de
binationaux juste pour obtenir le vote
des députés n'y changera
rienne personne n'a été dupe cet article
ne concerne que les binationaux et pas
les uninationaux sauf à fabriquer des
apatrides ce que les traités signés par
la France l'interdisent quelle catégorie
de citoyens de seconde zone crét-on ici
comment parler encore ici d'unité
nationale au nom de cette unité je vous
le rappelle celle-ci souhaitait vraiment
le général de Gaul à la sortie de la
guerre dans une France meurtrie préférra
pour les collaborateurs actives
l'indignité nationale à la déchéance là
il y avait un symbole fort ne
pourrions-nous pas opter pour la même
démarche pourquoi ne pas consacrer tous
nos efforts à nous mobiliser autour de
la prévention et de la réduction des
menaces que le terrorisme fait peser sur
notre corps social en y mettant à la
fois plus d'intelligence et plus de
pragmatisme pourquoi modifier notre
Constitution dans laquelle doivent se
reconnaître des millions de Français en
y insérant un article cééra inspiré de
l'extrême droite qui ne s'appliquera au
mieux qu'à une poignée d'individus ne
méritant certainement certainement pas
d'être même mentionné dans la Charte
fondatrice de notre République
avons-nous pensé à l'usage que pourrait
en faire cette extrême droite si un jour
elle arrivait au
pouvoir comme le résume très bien l'avis
de la Commission nationale consultative
des droits de l'homme en
constitutionnalisant la déchéance de
nationalité je cite ce sont les
fondement même du pacte républicain qui
se voit remis en en cause alors que non
sans paradoxe cette remise en cause est
l'un des objectifs poursuivis par les
auteurs d'actes de
terrorisme exécutive législateur acteur
de la société civile il nous incombe
aujourd'hui de ne pas céder à la
facilité ni un doute douteux confort
intellectuel et ce en mémoire des
victimes l'inflation législative n'est
rien d'autre des lois oui mais en nombre
raisonnable et raisonnable
elle-même à associé à un grand nombre
d'autres outils de compréhension et
d'action du terrorisme pour ces motifs
le groupe écologiste s'opposera à la
constitutionnalisation des deux mesures
dont nous débattons je vous remercie mes
chers collègues les deux articles
principaux de ce projet de loi peuvent
paraître sans point commun pourtant ils
partagent le même ADN ils ont en commun
cette peur que j'évoquais la peur du
quotidien pour l'une de la menace
annoncée martelée la peur de l'autre
pour la seconde cette révision
constitutionnelle est aujourd'hui
débattue alors que depuis
1986 plus de 20 lois censé protéger
notre pays contre le terrorisme ont été
voté quelle efficacité quelle utilité à
terme l'inefficacité l'inutilité ce sont
deux reproches qui sont souvent sur les
lèvres de nombreux détracteurs de votre
projet monsieur le Premier ministre
détacteurs présents sur tous les bancs y
compris ceux de votre propre parti
peut-être avant de vous précipiter dans
un contexte peu propice à la réflexion
aurait-il fallu écouter consulter
comprendre et sans doute penser dans le
silence de ses passions comme
jean-chacques Rousseau le recommandait
le premier point de votre projet de loi
c'est la constitutionnalisation de
l'état d'urgence votre justification
celle d'une sécurisation d'un état
d'exception à a vite été balayé par la
plupart des observateurs et professeurs
professeurs de droit constitutionnel
devant la commission de l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez même vendu la mèche
si je peux me permettre conférer une
base constitutionnelle à l'état
d'urgence c'est consolider les mesures
de police administrative défin par la
loi de
1955 le professeur Olivier beau
auditionné par la commission des lois l'
affirmé sans ambage je cite la
constitutionnalisation n'est pas
innocente loin dans cadrer les
conditions de l'état d'urgence elle
permet d'aller plus loin dans la
répression et aggrave les atteintes aux
libertés oui nous sommes en guerre tout
simplement parce que on a déclaré la
guerre depuis l'étranger à la France
certains l'oublie trop
vite certains même ont pu considérer que
le terme de guerre était un terme trop
fort trop militaire je voudrais leur
rappeler cette phrase vous ne vous
intéressez pas à la guerre mais la
guerre elle s'intéresse à vous une
phrase de Trotski en d'autres
termes en d'autres
termes cité cité par Jean
ledrillant en d'autres termes vous
pouvez vous pouvez vouloir pour un temps
vous pouvez vouloir ignorer vos ennemis
jusqu'au moment où eux ont décidé de ne
pas vous ignorer et nous y sommes
évidemment oui nous sommes en guerre la
menace est là elle est planétaire elle
est sur notre sol elle est aigu elle n'a
jamais été aussi aigu vous nous l'avez
les uns et les autres suffisamment
rappelé elle est permanente elle est
durable
elle est durable et il faut nous armer
évidemment sur tous les plans y compris
sur le plan juridique nous ne devons
avoir qu'une seule obsession la
protection
la protection de la France évidemment
face à cette barbarie face ch Michel
Mercier qui CIT tout à l'heure àent ce
qu' aurait pu appeler cette fiction
monstrueusement
cohérente c'est ce que nous avons voulu
régulièrement faire Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ici en soutenant tous les
textes de la lutte contre le terrorisme
tous pas moins due
demiaine tous
jamais notre majorité ne vous a manqué
dès lors que il s'agissait de l'intérêts
supérieurs du pays jamais et c'est avec
le même esprit de responsabilité que
nous avons accueilli il y a 4 mois très
exactement jour pour jour les
propositions du président de la
République dans sa déclaration il y
avait la proposition qui nous a surpris
à l'époque de révision constitutionnelle
avec ces deux volets
l'état d'urgence et puis la déchéance
sur le premier volet évidemment quelques
doutes mais pas d'hésitation sur le fond
pas d'hésitation pour le fond parce que
nous avons pour ce qui nous concerne
pour ce qui concerne mon groupe toujours
considérer qu'il n'y a pas d'opposition
entre d'une part la liberté publique et
d'autre part l'ordre public c'est-à-dire
et je l'ai déjà dit ici que la liberté
et la sécurité ne sont pas des sœurs
ennemis elles sont des sœurs siamoises
donc pas d'opposition
sur le fond un doute une hésitation bien
sûr et Philipp B l' magistralement
rappelé tout à l'heure est-ce que ça
nécessitait une réforme de la
Constitution je me rends à ces arguments
je me rends aussi aux arguments de la
vie du Conseil d'État en revanche sur le
deuxème volet les choses ont été très
différentes et le débat s'est enflammé
il s'est enflammé très vite pour ce qui
concerne la déchéance de nationalité je
voudrais y revenir un instant pour
expliquer la position du groupe le plus
complètement possible
et si finalement et si finalement mes
chers collègues il est juste que la
qualité de Français puisse s'acquérir
par le droit du sol il est aussi
parfaitement légitime que la qualité de
Français puisse se perdre par le prix du
sang le sang des Français versé le sang
des Français
massacrés alors bien s il reste une
difficulté et je l'aborderai monsieur le
Premier ministre comme vous l'avez fait
au moins dans les termes et dans la
proclamation sans détours et avec
franchise la
patridie je voudrais non pas vous
convaincre mais expliquer
etlever un certain nombre de
préventions la première l'égalité vous
aviez à l'Assemblée nationale moins ici
mais c'est à l'assemblée que vous aviez
exprimé assez clairement cette idée que
ce qui vous heurtait c'était la question
de l'égalité et vous aviez dit très
exactement pour que il y ait
responsabilité égale devant chacun il
doit y avoir égalité aussi devant la
sanction ce sont vos termes très exact
mais il n'y a pas d'égalité aujourd'hui
devant la sanction il n'y a pas
d'égalité dans le Code civil puisque
pour les
binationaux c'est le sujet de
l'acquisition et pas de la naissance et
demain et demain entre les binationaux
et les mononationaux et bien la
déchéance friverait les seconds les
mononationaux de toute patrie alors que
pour les binationaux évidemment il
resterait toujours une patrie donc le
concept de légalité il n'opère pas ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit vous souriez
mais vous allez moins sourire quand vous
relirez l'AVE du Conseil d'État c'est
l'AVE du Conseil d'État que je viens
d'exprimer en d'autres termes Monsieur
le Premier Ministre avec conviction mais
pour vous convaincre aussi que ce
concept d'égalité et que cette passion
de l'égalité peut nous égarer nous avons
voté les excellents amendements de la
commission des lois et du président bas
mais personnellement je voterai contre
l'article 1er parce que les postures bon
soyons pas DUP et puis c'est normal nous
sommes une assemblée politique et il
faut que nous rests une assemblée
politique c'est toujours une bonne chose
mais quand même euh j'ai j'ai sous les
yeux ça me rappelle ce qu'a dit euh
notre excellent collègue et ami le
président
Guillaume pour moi il ne peut pas y
avoir de réforme constitutionnelle s'il
n'y a que l'article 1 alors écoutez il y
en a qui disent faut supprimer l'article
2 il y en autres qui disent et bien s'il
n'y a que l'article 1 ça sert à rien on
ne peut mieux dire que l'article 1 ne
sert à rien c'est ça là je crois que
nous en avons la démonstration et et et
le problème et le problème là pour nous
pour nous il n'y a non non c'est pas
sorti du contexte je peux vous tenez
c'est là hein bon et on peut reprendre
le Journal Officiel aussi si c'est
nécessaire mais d'ailleurs c'est très
bien moi ça ne me choque pas la question
la question fondamental et de
savoir non pas si l'état
d'urgence doit être ou non appliqué il y
a des responsabilité gouvernementale et
en contrôle du Parlement la question
pour nous est de savoir s'il doit être
constitutionnalisé et nous nous
considérons majoritairement et c'est
notre droit c'est notre approche que ça
ne sert strictement à rien en dépit de
tout ce que l'on a essayé de nous
expliquer savemment au niveau du droit
alors les symboles c'est extrêmement
intéressant mais faisons du droit la
constitutionnalisation il est évident
que ça n'apporte rien et s'il ne restait
que l'article 1 ben ça ne servirait
encore moins àel quelque chose je ne
vous le fais pas dire et mes propos font
écho aux propos du Premier ministre hier
qui a voulu si je dire en provoquant
avec des mots très durs notre haute
assemblée pour indiquer que nous avons
fait des pas et l'article 1 est un
exemple où la constitutionalisation de
l'état d'urgence nous laissait perplexe
nous allons l'adopter c'est aussi une
maintendue que nous faisons vis-à-vis du
propos du président public et des
engagements qu'il a pris au Congrès à
Versailles mais peut-être pour un écho à
ce à ce que dit notre notre collègue
maçon et puis hier nous avons beaucoup
évoqué Anna arent et revenu je je cite
de de mémoire un un
passage un passage de l'État totalitaire
où où elle dit que les les méthodes
utilisées par les États totalitaires
pour faire face au problèmes auquels ils
ont donc à faire face
survivront à leur
défaite j'ai l'impression que vouloir
régler de tels problèmes par des
méthodes uniquement en augmentant les
contraintes policières les contraintes
diverses enfin et cetera c'est c'est pas
la voie suivie par les démocraties même
s'il faut pas avoir d'illusion même si
précisément il faut avoir des des outils
d'exception pour faire face aux périodes
excep au défi exceptionnel mais
précisément le problème c'est que si on
les institutionnalise et bien à partir
de ce moment-là c'est le régime
ordinaire donc je crois que le travail
d'équilibre qu'on essae qu'on essae de
faire insuffisant à mon avis mais c'est
déjà mieux ce que nous faisons que le
texte qui nous est venu de de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est
effectivement faire un exercice
démocratique difficile qui peut penser
on peut penser qu'il manque un peu de
logique mais c'est ça il faut qu' quand
même un jour et je le dis avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour Pier Colomba qui
est un grand
républicain il faut quand même se dire
on ne peut pas
constamment avoir une espèce de remise
en cause de ce qu entre guillemets d'un
côté la démocratie et de l'autre côté
l'ordre républiain l'ordre ain la
sécurité républicaine ça a du
sens franchement l'autorité de l'État
c'est le fondement de l'égalité c'est le
fondement de de la sécurité des gens un
état qui n'a pas d'autorité qui n'a pas
de de mesure dans la constitution ou par
la loi que ce soit l'état d'urgence que
ce soit d'autres mesures c'est un état
faibleble qui ne peut pas rassurer les
citoyens et alors c'est la porte ouverte
à tous les à tous les extrémismes à
toutes les organisations locales à
toutes les milices et à tout ce qu'on
veut franchement je je je je veux dire
que lorsque la représentation nationale
lorsqu'un gouvernement dans la
République de manière républicaine
organise l'état d'urgence organise un
certain nombre de mesures demande à la
police de la République à l'armée de la
République à la gendarmerie de la
République d'assurer l'ordre je préfère
l'ordre républicain au désordre des
extrêmes et au désordre des extrêmes qui
poussera à des communautarismes alors
l'état d'urgence dans la Constitution
moi j'étais pas forcément pour
l'intégrer mais en tout état de cause
que l'état d'urgence existe en lui-même
que les mesures prises y compris dans la
Constitution avec l'état de siège existe
c'est la force d'une démocratie sous le
contrôle du Parlement de pouvoir
l'exercer eu mon groupe dans sa majorité
a demandé la suppression de cet article
nous reconnaissons euh les améliorations
apportées à cet article grâce aux
travaux euh de la Commission et de
Monsieur bas que je salue euh nous ne
sommes pas convaincus par l'article 1er
euh de la enfin par c'est la
constitutionnalisation de cet article
1er parce que euh de sur croi nous
voyons plutôt des inconvénients surtout
une euh éventuelle pérénisation de
l'état d'urgence ce qui peut s'avérer
euh à la longue euh dangereux sans
compter la posture politique que
représente cette
constitutionnalisation il serait euh en
plus
inoortant de participer à cette posture
surtout que cette
constitutionnalisation risque en l'état
puisque elle elle ne sera pas voté à
l'identique dans les deux chambres
d'être envoyé au calandre grec avant
l'été nous avons acquis la conviction
que dès lors que l'état d'urgence n'est
pas une simple péripétie il est
nécessaire que des garanties soient
inscrites dans la Constitution quant à
l'utilisation de ce
dispositif nous avons travaillé me
semble-t-il de façon particulièrement
efficace notamment hier soir autour de
l'idée
d'inscrire la
proportionnalité
sur le thème de l'état d'urgence dans la
Constitution premièrement deuxièmement
de rappeler les prérogatives de
l'autorité judiciaire gardienne de la
liberté individuelle et aussi de
peaufiner de ciseler même le contrôle du
Parlement un contrôle permanent du
Parlement quant à l'exécution de l'état
d'urgence je crois sincèrement que le
travail qui a été mené au Sénat depuis
quelques heures qui est l'aboutissement
d'ailleurs d'un long travail en amont
est un véritable travail de constituant
dont nous pouvons nous honorer et je
pense que il serait légitime que le
maximum de sénateurs et de sénatrices
sur tous les bancs puissent voter cet
article premier je vous remercie pendant
l'état d'urgence la démocratie continue
la preuve les élections régionales se
sont tenues tout à fait normalement nous
n'avons cessé de
légiférer la possibilité est entière
pour le gouvernement d'engager j'ai sa
responsabilité devant l'Assemblée
nationale l'Assemblée nationale
peut-être dissoute et le Parlement peut
réviser la Constitution la preuve c'est
ce que nous sommes en train de faire et
nous ne le faisons pas sous la menace
nous le faisons comme participant au
pouvoir constituant souverain et par
conséquent je crois que il faut quand
même être très attentif donner une telle
extension au aux situations dans
lesquelles nous n'aurions plus le droit
d'exercer notre pouvoir
souverain et notamment celui de réviser
la Constitution c'est quelque chose qui
est privatif de droits fondamentaux de
la représentation
nationale je comprends que le général de
Gaulle et le pouvoir constituant en 1958
est interdit de réviser la Constitution
quand l'intégrité du territoire est
atteinte mais oui bien sûr si vous êtes
sous le coup d'une occupation étrangère
vous n'allez pas réviser votre
constitution pour créer une dictature ça
va de soi mais dans les autres cas je
crois qu'il faut être prudent de ne pas
hypothéquer ainsi par avance notre droit
souverain de réviser la
Constitution voici le résultat du
scrutin numéro 180 sur l'article
1er nombre de votants
346 nombre de suffrages exprimés
339 pour l'adoption
30001 contre 38 le Sénat a adopté il y a
quelques années en 2010 quand la
majorité à laquelle j'appartenais
envisageer la déchéance de nationalité
des cris d'or frais étaient poussés
remettre en cause l'appartenance à notre
nation d'individus ayant pris les armes
contre les dépositaires de l'autorité
publique constitu une atteinte
intolérable au principes constitutifs de
la nation une entorse à la tradition
républicaine que n'avions-nous pas
entendu de la part de ceux qui
aujourd'hui professent le contraire
justement au nom de la République on
admet que la nationalité peut être
retiré selon cet article 2 pour un crime
ou un délit constituant une atteinte
grave à la vie de la nation nous
pouvions donc dire que nous étions
prophétiques cette fois-ci c'est une
majorité d'orientation différente qui
admet dans la norme fondamentale cette
déchéance de nationalité comment ne pas
s'en réjouir j'approuve cette volonté de
faciliter la tâche du législateur en lui
donnant cet appui le plus solide qu'est
la Constitution au demeurant il s'agit
d'étendre le domaine reconnu au
législateur prévu par l'article 34 de la
Constitution nous précisons juste un
alinéa de cet article à cet égard je
rends hommage à la capacité de notre 5e
République à s'adapter à un contexte de
crise et à la plasticité de sa
constitution tout ce qui permet à notre
pays de se séparer de ceux qui
l'assassinent va dans le bon sens j'ai
toujours été opposé à l'idée de la
déchéance de nationalité et plus encore
pour la déchéance de nationalité des
Français nés français c'est un vieux
combat je l'ai mené quand l'extrême
droite voulait relancer ses thèses je
l'ai mené quand une partie de la droite
a essayé de nous expliquer qu'il fallait
l'inscrire dans la Constitution je le
mène aujourd'hui
plus encore
qu'hier plus encore qu'hier
pourquoi parce que s'il est vrai que le
terrorisme est un enjeu
considérable qui doit mobiliser toute la
nation la manière de le le combattre
procède de trois
exigences la première l'efficacité dans
la prévention des actes organiser nos
forces de police notre justice nos
forces de renseignement et chacun le en
convient la déchéance de nationalité n'a
aucune efficacité en la matière le
deuxème la deuxième exigence c'est de ne
rien céder sur les principes et pour ma
part je considère que le cadre qui fait
la Nation c'est-à-dire le cadre de la
nationalité est un principe fondamental
on peut avoir des désaccords entre nous
et il y en a on peut avoir ce débat
entre nous et nous le maintiendront mais
un moment où tout est fait pour Ess
essayer de mettre des brèches dans ce
qui sont les failles ou les désaccords
qui sont légitimes en démocratie ce
n'est pas le moment de remettre en cause
les principes d'autant quand ça n'a
aucune
efficacité
troisièmement on nous dit que ça va
rassembler les Français en aucune façon
ça ne rassemblera ça ne nous rassemble
pas déjà entre nous et dans l'histoire
ça ne nous a pas
rassemblé mais plus encore avec le
principe que monsieur maluret vient de
décrire soit on fait à côté des
apatrides et moi je suis toujours été
contre l'apatridie c'est la charge de
l'histoire la France des droits de
l'homme doit non seulement la réduire
mais la combattre la patriedie mais mais
aussi si ce n'est pas cela c'est qu'il y
aura différenciation donc inégalité par
rapport au droit qu'elle soit de fait
écrit par une méthode ou par une autre
il y a dans l'idée de déchéance une
forme
d'autoexonération il y a deux discours
celui qui affirme que ces terroristes ne
sont pas de vrais Français et l'autre
discours qui soutient qui ne sont pas de
vrais musulmans d'un côté comme de
l'autre il y a et du vrai mais aussi du
dénis or pour combattre le terroriste
nous avons besoin de percer le
fonctionnement du terrorisme djihadiste
en brandissant la déchéance nous
enclenchons un engrenage de solidarité
absurde la déchéance est la plus
mauvaise des réponses symboliques car
elle dessine des frontières juridiques
au cord d'eau en assignant en fonction
de l'identité le camp des bons et celui
des suspects les suspects ceux qui par
leur patronyme leur aspect physique leur
foi réel ou supposé se retrouvent dans
une injonction paradoxale lorsqu'ils se
taisent ils sont forcément dans
lacomplicité et quand ils s'expriment
ils signeraient leur duplicité pour ma
part je dénonce depuis des années la
wabisation de l'islam mondial plus
l'Islam traditionnel culturel
spirituelle est mise en cause et la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
Français de confession musulmane a été
vécu comme une mise en cause de cette
nature plus les arguments des promoteurs
du fondamentaliste prospèrent je
remercie jean-Pierre Sueur de sêtre
élevé ici contre les propos du sénateur
maçon grand professionnel de l'amalgame
pour qui la les binationaux seraient une
5è colonne tout ce qui est excessif est
vraiment
insignifiant pour combattre le
terrorisme jihadiste nous devons enrayer
l'offensive de l'islam intégriste ce
combat là ne peut se faire sans les
Français de confession musulmane et pour
associer nos compatriotes ni
victimisation ni stigmatisation et
encore moins la et encore moins la
suspicion or c'est bien le mode
d'expression le plus répendu le plus
lâche et le plus sournoir il faut juste
les reconnaître comme des égau des
Français à part entière or la déchéance
de nationalité donne une prime à
l'identité sur la citoyenneté à
contrario si collectivement nous
parvenions à promouvoir l'égalité
formelle et l'égalité des chances à
endiguer l'intégrisme dans nos
territoires et sur les réseaux sociaux
sans stigmatiser les Français de
confession musulmanes nous offrirons
àors
un beau visage à la laïcité et nous
aurons avec nous dans le combat contre
le terrorisme la nation réunie je vous
remercie en ce qui me concerne je
voterai sans hésitation la déchance de
nationalité dans la définition amendée
par notre commission des lois la mesure
est certes symbolique j'en conviens mais
qui commet un crime de terrorisme
s'exclut du cadre national je voterai
toujours sans hésitation l'article 2 en
ce qu'il concerve l'attribution comme la
déchance de nationalité dans l'autorité
de l'exécutif il serait d'ailleurs
paradoxal de constitutionnaliser une
peine complémentaire ce qui serait le
cas dans la version initiale du texte
alors que les peines principales ne le
sont pas je ne souhaite pas plus
m'engager sur la voie aventureuse et peu
glorieuse de la patrie dans un débat où
beaucoup sinon tout a été dit ceci se
comprend au regard de sa charge
émotionnelle où l'on convoque histoire
culture et valeur je
maintiens avec conviction le fait que ce
texte n'est pas un texte de
rassemblement tel qu'il est je maintiens
le fait que sa constittu la
constitutionnalisation sur la déchéance
de nationalité d'ailleurs comme sur
l'état d'urgence n'est pas
utile et que certes on nous a dit
longuement hier et encore aujourd'hui
qu'il s'agissait d'un
symbole moi je suis toujours inquiet
quand on parle plus de symbolle que de
règle de
droit ce qui est important c'est d'avoir
une règle de droit adapté aux besoins de
l'évolution de la société certes donc la
loi n'est pas
la Constitution non plus on peut la
réviser mais
utiliser un projet de loi de révision
constitutionnel pour des
objectifs qui me paraissent
malheureusement peu conformes avec
l'idée de rassemblement je crois que ce
n'est pas bien et
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la voie qui
doit être choisie pour rassembler les
Français dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme nous nous sommes tous ici
convaincus qu'il est nécessaire et que
tout doit être fait pour lutter contre
les terroristes au point de vue matériel
au point de vue humain voire des
modifications législatives et il y en a
eu d'ailleurs lorsque l'état d'urgence
la loi est venue en discussion ici ça a
été très bien fait maintenant arrêtons
je dirais que l'urgence mes chers
collègues l'urgence c'est que ce projet
de révision constitutionnelle tombe en
déchéance
monsieur le Président je demande la
priorité sur l'amendement de la
commission dont le numéro est le
14 s'en suivra naturellement que cette
priorité devrait s'étendre logiquement
aux amendements qui suivent cet
amendement 14 nous sommes
à un moment important de de nos de nos
discussions
et
essayer pas de vous convaincre en tout
cas de rappeler un certain nombre
d'arguments qui amèent le gouvernement à
donner un avis défavorable à cet
amendement numéro
14 le débat est nourri riche des
interventions d'une très grande qualité
nous l'avons les uns les autres compris
et c'est vrai c'est vrai
que pas vrai forcément sur tous les
bancs et c'est tout à fait respect
mais c'est vrai que c'est ces attentats
terribles nous l'avons tous dit avec nos
mots ont sans doute amené nos
compatriotes à repenser chacun qu'est-ce
que cela voulait dire être français et à
réfléchir au fond à cette belle idée si
française qui est la nation c'est
vrai vous pré vous préférez c'est le
cœur de la discussion bien sûr une
déchéance de nationalité prononcée
seulement contre certains terroristes en
l'occurrence lesb naationaux là où le
gouvernement et l'Assemblée visaient
tous les terroristes sans
distinction et donc c'est là où je ne
suis pas le président retillot et je ne
vous suis pas il faut que vous
expliquiez à nos concitoyens là aussi
cette
exigence à géométrie variable le mot est
peut-être pas bien choisi selon que l'on
est mononational ou pas même si encore
une fois nous parlons de terroristes
ayant commis des actes barbares le
gouvernement et une majorité des 35è à
l'Assemblée national ont proposé une
solution qui limite considérablement le
risque de créer des apatrie détenteur en
France ça a été rappelé d'ailleurs dans
les débatères d'un statut protecteur des
droits élémentaires le débat il est là
en
1958 la République est menacé par les
guerres coloniales la guerre
d'Algérie l'État est menacé la fin de la
2uxè Guerre mondiale n'a que 13 ans le
souvenir de Vichy est là
partout et donc la constitution de 58 en
réalité s'appuie sur l'état et la
République parle peu de la nation
l'article clevin le Gouvernement
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation mais finalement la nation elle
n'apparît qu'assez peu dans la
Constitution parce qu'elle n'est pas en
cause parce qu'elle n'est pas remise en
cause et parce que l'identité nationale
et la nation française en 1958 n'est pas
un problème n'est pas une difficulté
n'est pas une interrogation en 2016 elle
l' elle est
l'interpellation le terrorisme mais
avant même le terrorisme le doute le
scepticisme sur ce qu'est la nation
française depuis 10 ans c'est vrai c'est
vrai les Français se demandent ce
qui'est la France aujourd'hui les
Français ce que demandent se demandent
ce qui est notre destin commun alors
inscrire les éléments sur la déchéance
et sur ce qu'est la nation dans la
Constitution oui c'est un geste fort et
c'est un geste fort au-delà du
terrorisme parce que la question de la
nation devient une question essentielle
pour ce qui notre République et notre
pays il n'y a pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale si l'on évoque la
double nationalité et il n'y a pas de
majorité au Sénat si on la refuse nous
sommes donc dans cette situation de
blocage la logique voudrait dire qu'à
partir de là nous nous arrêtons dans la
démarche et nous passons à autre chose
considérant qu'il a d'autres enjeux dans
le pays à traiter mais la question qu'on
peut se poser de savoir pourquoi on
arrive à ce blocage on arrive à ce
blocage pour une raison assez simple et
que personne n'évoque ici c'est que la
question est mal posée on définit pas la
nation en regard ant vers l'arrière le
débat sur l'identité nationale l'a
montré l'a révélé les blocages les
impasses les ambiguïtés de ce débat ont
été il y a quelques années évidents et
ont mis mal à l'aise toute la nation
française le problème c'est que en
organisant le débat sur la déchéance
nous avons voulu regarder effectivement
le débat de cette façon la nation nous
devons la définir vers l'avant en
regardant vers l'avant en lui
construisant un avenir et si nous
voulions mettre en place une mesure
symbolique ce n'est pas en exclu les
terroristes de la communauté nationale
c'est en intégrant dans la communauté
nationale comme l'ont fait nos ancêtres
de la Révolution française avec la
formule des citoyens d'honneur ceux qui
se battent contre de ont des conditions
épouvantables pourquoi par exemple ne
pas donner alors la citoyenneté
d'honneur à ces femmes CDES qui se
battent contre daesh là-bas en Syrie et
sur le territoire de l'Irak ça c l'
aurait un sens ça c'est un symbole ça
sexprimera une France qui va vers
l'avant qui regarde loin devant elle et
pas simplement pour régler des comptes
avec ceux qu'elle a simplement à
sanctionner à punir mais pas à exclure
parce que la République n'exclut pas
elle se définit d'une autre manière si
nous avions et moi j'avais des doutes
quant à la crédibilité de ce qui a été
voté par l'Assemblée nationale ou dans
quant à sa cohérence j'ai davantage
encore de doute sur l'amendement qui
nous est proposé car cet amendement est
très clair la déchéance ne
s'appliquerait qu'au bit nationaux point
j'ai dit tout à
l'heure que bien entendu il s'agit de
criminel et il s'agit de personnes qui
s'exclut d'une certaine manière
elle-même de toute nationalité
d'ailleurs
mais nous savons et moi j'ai toujours
cela présent à
l'esprit que le texte tel qu'il a été
présenté a pour effet collatéral que les
5 millions de binationaux qui sont en
France perçoivent cela comme une
inégalité vous avez dit ce
qui la nation mais c'est ni à vous ni à
moi d'ailleurs de le dire la
Constitution définit ce qu'est la France
la France je parle pas de telle ou telle
institution non la Constitution dans son
premier article dit la France est une
publique indivisible laïque démocratique
et sociale elle assure l'égalité devant
la loi de tous les citoyens sans
distinction d'origine de race ou de
religion je répète elle dit la France
est une république elle définit la
France comme une république et elle ne
définit pas la France à partir de
l'appréciation qu'à chacun de ce qui'est
l'identité parce que ça ça nous divise
bon je vais pas faire de grand discours
vous savez que de toute façon nous
sommes opposés à la déchéance de de
nationalité et que bien évidemment nous
ne pouvons accepter cet amendement 14
qui rétablit la déchéance des
binationaux pourquoi parce que je l'ai
déjà dit aussi et nous l'avons dit cela
est porteur d'une
stigmatisation de l'ensemble de ceux qui
portent au moins deux nationalités
puisqu'on peut en avoir plus que plus
que deux et qui même si ils n'ont
strictement rien à voir avec le débat
sur le terrorisme ce sont
poter du doigt comme finalement n'étant
pas tout à fait Français comme les
autres donc refus absolu de de voter en
faveur de cet amendement unanimement le
groupe socialiste républicain votera
contre l'amendement numéro 14 et votera
contre l'article l'article 2 pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord je crois que
ce qui vient de se passer tout au long
de de ces de jours a été un débat
intéressant parfois vif et les uns et
les autres ont pu exprimer leur leur
leur position ça n'a échappé à personne
que dans notre groupe le groupe
socialiste nous n'avons pas la la même
position les uns et les autres c'est
bien normal sur un sujet comme celui-ci
la clause de conscience doit jouer
chacun doit doit l'exprimer une
trentaine de nos collègues ont même
présenté un amendement pour supprimer le
pour supprimer l'article 2 parce qu'ils
sont contre la déchéance de nationalité
que ce soit dans la version Assemblée
nationale que soit dans la version
nouvelle version qui va être votée
présentée par le président de de de de
la commission une un plus grand nombre
souhaite arriver à un accord dans un au
Congrès et que l'on arrive à trouver une
solution et cette solution elle doit
passer le premier ministre l'a très bien
dit tout à l'heure par une avancée des
deux chambres à la fois l'Assemblée
nationale et à la fois le le le le Sénat
tout le monde l'a dit depuis 2 jours
quel que soi les positions que nous
parlons de terrorisme que la France a
été touché qu'il faut des réponses et
que le discours du du président de la
République Congrès de Versailles il n
pas été jugé sur telle ou telle phrase
il a été jugé sur sur sur son sur son
ensemble un point d'accord avec le
Premier ministre sur le départ sur ce
qui explique notre présence ici d'abord
le
terrorisme le point de départ c'est
aussi la déclaration du Président de la
République et sa proposition de modifier
la Constitution nous n'avions rien
demandé comme la rappelé tout à l'heure
François quetto c'est le point de
départ deuxème observation nous avons
jugé que pour autant cette idée de la
déchéance pouvait être utile parce que
elle nous renvoie ce que nous sommes et
nous pensons que si la lutte est longue
notre capacité à mener le combat c'est
aussi notre capacité à reprendre
possession des raisons qui font que nous
sommes ensemble qui font que nous sommes
un peuple parce que dans une démocratie
on lutte avec les armes on lutte avec
des arsenaux juridiques mais on lutte
d'abord avec les volontés pas seulement
individuelles parce que la France vous
le savez ça n'est pas une justpposition
d'individu la France ça n'est pas non
plus un archipel de communauté ou un
archipel de tribu donc ce débat est
important il est important un moment où
trop souvent on a encouragé ici ou là la
dépolitisation de la vie des peuples la
réduction de la vie des peuples aux
conditions de leur existence matérielle
en oubliant de leur parler de ce qu'ils
sont et nous sommes une nation civique
c'est la France qui a inventé cette
forme particulière d're je
maintiens avec conviction le fait que ce
texte n'est pas un texte de
rassemblement tel qu'il est je maintiens
le fait que sa constitu la
constitutionnalisation sur la déchéance
de nationalité d'ailleurs comme sur
l'état d'urgence n'est pas
utile et que certes on nous a dit
longuement hier et encore aujourd'hui
qu'il s'agissait d'un
symbole moi je suis toujours
inquiet quand on parle plus de symbolle
que de règles de
droit ce qui est important c'est d'avoir
une règle de droit adapté aux besoins de
l'évolution de la société certes donc la
loi n'est pas immuable la Constitution
non plus on peut la réviser mais
utiliser un projet de loi de révision
constitutionnel pour des
objectifs qui me paraissent
malheureusement peu conformes avec
l'idée de rassemblement je crois que ce
n'est pas bien et
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la voie qui
doit être choisie pour rassembler les
Français dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme nous sommes tous tous ici
convaincus qu'il est nécessaire et que
tout doit être fait pour lutter contre
les terroristes au point de vue matériel
au point de vue humain voire des
modifications législatives et il y en a
eu d'ailleurs lorsque l'état d'urgence
la loi est venu en discussion ici ça a
été très bien fait maintenant arrêtons
je dirais que l'urgence mes chers
collègues
l'urgence c'est que ce projet de
révision constitutionnelle tombe en
déchéance bien chers collègues voici le
résultat du scrutin numéro 183 sur
l'article 2 nombre de votants 344 nombre
de suffrages exprimés
336 pour l'adoption
186 contre 150 le Sénat a adopté
l'article
2 il s'agit ici d'insérer après
l'article 2 un article permettant
désormais au résident de nationalité
étrangèr de pouvoir voter en France lors
des élections locales il a souvent été
des questions de symbole ici dans notre
hémicycle en voilà un accorder le droit
de vote à des milliers d'hommes et de
femmes vivant en France travaillant en
France et payant leurs impôts en France
au-delà de ce symbole il s'agit avant
tout d'un signal fort la République
intègre rassemble et assure l'égalité en
son sein le droit de vote des résidents
étrangers est un formidable outil
d'intégration non seulement pour les
étrangers eux-mêmes mais aussi pour
leurs familles pour leurs enfants pour
leurs proches car comment montrer
l'exemple et encourager au vote quand on
est soi-même privé de ce droit il serait
également un formidable rempart contre
le communitarisme en associant tous les
citoyens d'où qu'ils viennent au choix
collectifs et aux décisions qui les
engagent mais aussi en marquant
l'appartenance à une même communauté de
quasi unanimement le groupe socialiste
républicain votera contre cette C ou
cette cet amendement sur l'explication
qui ont été donné par le président de la
commission et par le le le ministre
certains d'entre nous peuvent penser que
le droit de vote pour les pour les
étrangers est est quelque chose
d'important bon
certains oui bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
sauf que là je pense vraiment que tout à
l'heure les les les mots d'apaisement du
Premier ministre du président du
Président rotaillot si nous voulons
arriver à une réforme constitutionnelle
et si nous voulons faire en sorte de pas
trop mettre d'arrête je pense que ce
cette cet amendement que l'on soit pour
que l'on soit contre mais mis dans ce
texte constitutionnel ne ne collerait
pas c'est pas le bon véhicule et je
crois que c'est pas le moment c'est la
c'est la raison pour laquelle la quasi
unanimité de notre groupe vottera contre
donc je mets au voix ces deux
amendements avec deux avis défavorables
qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient ils
ne sont pas adopté voilà vous avez pu
suivre les meilleurs moments de l'examen
au Sénat du projet de loi de révision
constittution
le vote solennel sur l'ensemble du texte
aura lieu cet après-midi vous pourrez le
suivre bien sûr tout à l'heure en direct
sur notre
antenne